taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
hi taste buddies it's the taste buds
podcast
i'm joe derosa volcano we are
thrilled to have you with us today for
what i believe will be
a knock down drag out argument titans
the titans there's no other way to put
it they're both of them are not a number
they're both number ones
yeah these are pluses fighting against
each other these are dessert titans
what are you just in time for kong
versus versus
uh or is it joe lewis in that prime or
something or louis ali
right any any of your titan matches
louis ty who are you potassium in there
tyson do you put tyson in an all-time
match and a titan yeah
yes okay would i would have said tyson
versus ali you would have been fine with
that
tyson never fought ali no no no i'm
going with real things that happened
oh you're talking about godzilla versus
kong
[Music]
right frasier you're gonna say frasier
versus lilith
frazier lilith actually yes that counts
that counts sam versus diane
there is an episode of cheers where they
hit each other repeatedly in the face
you ever see that no
oh i mean they start slapping each other
back and forth in the face yeah it's
crazy
one day when we move off of possibly off
of foods and debating
sitcoms would be a great one oh dude uh
sitcoms be a great one i will we'll meet
there we'll meet this bring it on
we will do like like a because it's just
unlimited amount of foods but we always
plan to venture out into other topics so
yeah we actually actually you know what
now's a good chance let us know in the
comments what you think of that we we
talk about
at some point maybe if it's not foods
uh doing a season about you know pop
culture stuff video games
music bands you know same same show just
a different thing
let us know what you think of that we're
curious uh how you would feel
um in the meantime though we're still on
food and we're going to be on food for
quite some time
i can't imagine that people aren't going
to be outspoken about today's matchup
now this was suggested by my niece by
your niece
yeah you brought this in and said hi mia
hi mia
how you doing i went to dinner at my
family's house and she was like
throwing this out there cookies ice
cream i don't think you've done it
like every time i see people she says it
she talks like you like that
no she does she really did she she she
did say it like that
um i it's so funny because even my
little we've mentioned rainy solved too
like when i see people now like
a lot of times they lead with what they
think of matchup on this podcast
yeah like we're not even talking about
the podcast but i'll get texts calls or
like hey i ain't been good good
hey by the way you know what you should
do on tastebuds yeah i get that a lot
a lot i get it a lot i get up who said
to me the other day they yell at the
radio
when they listen who was that oh man it
was a so many people do i know burst
says he does but
yeah so many people it was a comedy
friend i forget but uh but they said you
know you love the show and i yell it
through oh oh it was uh eddie ift
oh okay said he listens to the show and
uh and he loves it he said i'm always
wrong
is that right i think in the beginning i
had momentum
but i've been reading comments lately
and they're swinging your way i think
you had a nice run of wins
that kind of put me in the doghouse with
people i'm gonna say this jersey the
movie seinfeld i mean the comedian with
seinfeld
sure yeah right and they said well you
know you're a big
star so you go on stage they must be
crazy and
they must love it he said that'll only
carry you for a few minutes yeah then
you got to deliver
and i think that's what's happened here
fighting words
fighting words oh
they all love you from the show
[Laughter]
i love it i don't know i've i've heard
that
uh i think that what i gleaned at least
in the beginning or well people thought
i
your arguments are were at least a
little bit all over the place and i
think that you got on
you make you make statements in like
absolutes and
i think you make crazy claims and i
think people had a hard time getting
behind him where i think i
at least at first i was had a much more
solid
kind of pragmatic approach to my
arguments
i well i think it is ebbs and flows
because there's been episodes where i
was flailing too
i think i think the show is i probably i
think i've said this on the show i think
the show is passion versus hubris
and uh and i think that's why it's
that's why it's insane and funny to
listen to i guess
the uh uh but uh i mean today
would you want to tell them what team
you're taking i can't even like
to me there's no question what team to
take i mean and i understand that
they're both
a-plus categories uh you know i
understand the match up
i understand it but there's there's only
one choice and it's cookies
there's only one choice cookies six
cookies over
ice cream i think cookies over you have
a death wish we could have thrown cake
in here too right
cake versus ice cream cookies versus
cake cake versus cookies versus ice
cream we didn't we went you took ice
cream i took cookies and ice and i'll
tell you
that i would have also taken cookies
versus cake oh
stop it sal you think cake so you think
cake and ice cream over cookies
yes 110
zillion percent wow i couldn't disagree
more a cookie is a
lovely snack uh it's a fun thing to eat
in bed
uh you know but it's not in the dessert
department when you go out and you have
a meal like when you go out and have a
meal i'm talking you go to a steakhouse
and you sit down and
and you get the jumbo shrimp cocktail to
start and you get
two bottles of wine and in the
porterhouse and and the creamed spinach
and you're really doing it up
at the end of the steakhouse yeah yeah
yeah yeah
at the end of that meal again so you're
at outback
yeah yeah nice place at the end of that
meal
you're not going garchan bring me some
cookies
you know what not a lot of restaurants
will do a fresh baked cookie some do it
and when they do it i always oblige a
lot of times on room service menu too
they'll have fresh baked cookies you get
choice of three with milk but cookies
granted are not
necessarily uh on the menu a lot as a
dessert item but i won't let you
use that as a strike against them for a
battle
of worthiest desserts i
i i understand but i do think it counts
i think there's something to be said
by the way are we in we started we're
stars you hit record
no i mean but we're starting the debate
because we sent the we already sent the
poll out right yes
okay so we're this is it we're doing it
oh we're in babes okay
i just want to make sure we were
officially in no we're in oh okay so
you i i hear what you're saying but you
you can use that as a as a valid
argument against it's you were talking
about the best dessert
and with that has to come uh
substantiality
substance and it's there's something to
be said that cookies are not served on
medicine ah that's a terrible argument
you're gonna lose
terrible arguments it's not that's a
terrible argument that's that's not my
whole argument that's part of me you
don't need to be on a menu at a
restaurant dude
cookie they're cookies it's not like
we're talking about a niche item here
you're talking about the best dessert
get this credit cookies because they're
not
traditionally on dessert at restaurants
so if i said if i said to you right now
you know what i think the best dessert
is
grapes you'd be like no it's not dude
why
because it's not it's not thrown into
the argument of desserts ever
ever it's not it's that's that's when
they bring the card around you don't see
cookies on the cart you don't see it and
when a place does have cookies for
dessert you go
are they really i mean come come on no
you know it's
why are you making the argument what
items are on a dessert menu at a
restaurant because we're arguing the
best desserts what do you mean
now we're arguing cookies versus ice
cream did the poll not say
better dessert yeah yeah it doesn't but
but
but cookies i don't have to i don't have
to i made my point i'll back off of that
argument yeah but no
i don't have that no one believes that
that's what's gonna make ice cream beat
cookies
i don't think it's what's gonna make it
beat it i think it's one of the things
that contributes to why it's a better
screen is on a menu because
because it's the king of desserts what
do you mean
it's tell me why tell me in what way our
ice cream
is not now we're i'm not a big ice cream
guy forget
that swear to christ i've taken
vacations
multiple vacations with you yeah you're
full of [ __ ] that's not true
you're full of what ice cream did you
see me just like when you said you mean
yeah i've gone to an ice cream shop with
a whole group of friends and i got an
ice cream cone
this is like when you said i'm not a big
drinker what are you talking about right
now
what are you talking i haven't drank in
a month and a half you want to have a
drink i said i haven't really either
but again if i have the one drink in a
month and a half
and you go oh stop it now and i poured a
drink and now people think i'm a drink
ice cream we we would go to the
supermarket you would buy multiple
gelatos and things you look you love
this stuff gelato is not ice cream
oh stop it not getting gelato just like
you're not getting sorbet
you're not getting there all right
listen i'm just saying you like
ice cream i don't not like it nobody
never saw you for dessert on those trips
cookies bro you are never one lying sack
of [ __ ] now
no i'm not dude i eat cookies all day
long so the cows come home i pop cookies
cookies i go get a cookie i go back i do
a little cup of tea i eat some gyms all
day long they're not a great dessert
you never see me eat a cookie that's
preposterous okay so tell me why
in all of its infinite just everything
ice cream you've got you've got vanilla
chocolate strawberry i'm not going to go
this way
look there's a million types of cookies
there's a billion types of ice cream
you you dare i mean cookies right you
got all the powerhouses that are
manufactured and branded
in a cookie aisle i'm not even really
talking about those i'm talking about
cookies in a more
general sense like homemade home run
bakery you can't talk because nobody's
making ice cream at home
i'm not doing that that's not true ice
cream is i know i know
i know somewhere in this universe people
do it at home
it's much more when i was little you had
to buy this like if you wanted to make
ice cream at home you had to buy this
like machine
and you poured all the things it took
overnight and you had to stir it and it
took a lot of like uh you know elbow
grease
and you put it in and now they have ice
cream makers that make ice cream in like
an hour at home i almost got one for my
mom
i understand but my point is like are a
lot of people making ice cream at home
no but again i don't think that's where
ice cream or cookies live or die anyway
then i'll give you another one then i'll
give you another one
okay why ice cream is better when you go
to
a uh buffet okay when you go to a buffet
and you go up after that buffet and you
say i want some dessert what do you
always find pimp
what do you always see at a buffet it's
cheap ice
an ice cream machine with a toppings bar
you never see trays of cookies you do
oh yes you do i'll go to china buffet
right now we'll hit pause i'll drive you
there
we'll go to the buffet on highland
boulevard over here you're going to see
an ice cream machine
you're going to see jello and pudding
you're going to see a couple of cakes
sliced up entrees and you're going to
see a whole tray of cookies
a whole truck this is not what i'm
saying man cookies are
crispy tell me what cookies are chewy
cookies chunky
milk cookies are fresh baked cookies are
hot and steamy
cookies have melted chocolate and they
have nuts okay they have fruit
ice cream ice cream they have creams
okay
they're vanilla every flavor under the
ice cream is cold
ice cream is cold ice cream has frozen
chocolate pieces ice cream can be crispy
because you can fry it
ice cream has dressings and toppings on
top of it hot fudge
whipped cream caramel cherry sauce
strawberry toppings sure options are
abundant in both
treats so tell me why a cookie is better
a cookie is biting into a crispy disc
better than a smooth swallow of a
wonderfully robust
very diverse fighter this big thing is
random table a crispy disc
versus a smooth sword what are we
arguing here we're swallowing what are
we
what do we do what do you mean a smooth
swallow what are we arguing here
are the cookies giving you trouble you
know what i you know what the cookie's
giving you trouble
you know what i'll you know what up you
know i'll prove to you
a baby you give me a cold glass of milk
and a fresh
cookie you could take the ice cream and
pump it into you with it like it was an
enema
i will prove to you just keep it i will
prove to you
that cookies ain't [ __ ] cooking in the
in the dessert department yeah and i'll
prove to you in two ways yeah ready
yeah ready graham cracker that's a
gram-flavored cookie right that's
considered a cookie
that's basically the flavor of your
animal crackers or whatever
graham cracker ice cream cone i've seen
it
you know what ice cream says hold me
you're beneath me hold me
you're here to hold me you know what a
chipwich says
the ice cream goes hold me get around me
and
hold and make it possible for them to
eat me with their hands
you [ __ ] losers cream needs a holder
because it's frozen liquid if you put a
scoop of ice cream in your palm
you're going to have issues right away
yeah it needs a holder yeah cookie is
its own holder give me 20 ingredients
that disc is holding all of them
okay i'm holding a cookie in my hand
there could be dozens of ingredients in
one
i'm dunking it i'm just losing the
texture softness
the bite i'm if it's if i'm eating it
hot right out of the oven
maybe oh here he goes here he goes
first of all ice cream is not a year
round tree cookies are i don't want ice
cream in the dead of winter i'm sorry i
just don't
you yes you do but then you don't want
to hustle on sunday in december
no you don't want a hot spot sunday in
december no you're not
specific and odd that you're asking me
no it's not easy
you want to bring seasons into it okay
why would you ask me a question that's
very easy to say
you're like you don't want a freezing
cold on sunday in december they're not
freezing cold
it's a hot fudge sundae cookies every
day of every year
dairy every cookie is a treat for all
seasons dairy queen
never would maybe name me a cookie
restaurant outside of a niche
like little like you know we didn't name
you a cookie restaurant this this
there's so many brands of cookies no no
no no name
cookie restaurant they have those are
they have those
you've seen an otis spunk by a
restaurant
no i swear to god at a restaurant you
idiot that's what i just said
name me a restaurant you don't have ice
cream restaurants you [ __ ] berry
queen is an ice cream restaurant
it's across the nation it's an ice cream
shop
friendlies is known for its ice cream
like you go to friendlies is not an ice
cream restaurant dude
but you go there for the ice cream you
don't go there for the cookies i go to i
can name any restaurant that i can go to
that has
good cookies dairy queen is an ice cream
fast food
the fact that dairy cream cream exists
makes
ice cream beet cookies in the battle of
what's a better dessert
cookies
i love insomnia cookies i said outside
of a niche mom-and-pop style
thing yeah all right so dairy queen is
going to be your great savior
it's up there with mcdonald's dairy
queen
thank you no it's not gallon mcdonald's
and dairy queen
are two different things there's a dairy
queen everywhere
you what does that have to do with
anything it's a restaurant devoted to
ice creams
ice cream has more chains than cookies
that doesn't make any sense in this
argument but fine
insomnia cookies mrs fields cookies no
no no
at the prudential center it's a stand at
the prudential center
you walk down the street you'll find a
man with a cart that sells ice cream
ice cream trucks ice cream trucks
when did you ever see a truck come
around with a jingle and see
children run outside to get it you've
never seen it
you've got an ice cream truck that's
because of the summer and that's because
ice cream caters to heat because it's a
cold treat
that's why you have to think that's the
only reason why you don't think this you
don't think you're getting any
drugs that sells cookies
cookies
[Music]
how could i forget how could i forget
oh my god cookies raise this young girl
i'm glad you brought this up cookies
holds young girls on their
shoulders it educates them yeah it
prepares them for the real world
you know who else does that's the point
you know who else does sales
yeah you know who else okay you know who
else claims to hold young girls up
pimps crash
[Music]
girls got cookies okay
gordon ramsay tried a girl scout cookie
for the first time in his life on the
jimmy kimmel show and
spit it out on the cookies floor
they're the worst cookies identity he
doesn't spit out that cookie he loses
they're the worst cookies around
terrible what would you just say gordon
ramsay's better cookie where on where
jimmy kimmel so you're telling me that
ice cream beats cookies because gordon
ramsay is a great
cookie on jimmy's girl scout cookies
suck
and i've had them in recent years
they're terrible they're terrible
cookies
okay all right they're bad
there's a cookies a place um a place
that i just got cookies from
in new york city it's the place
it's like it's it's the hottest thing
but when cronuts came out
yeah but you put yeah
it's such a good brand it's such a good
um this place inside
your cookies is great that's not my
point oh my god milk bar unbelievable
levine bakery is let me tell you
something right now
i will take a cookie from levine bakery
i will have a
when we do our first live which might be
by the way might be coming it might even
be a starter
you want to get in there brands we're
getting in each branch you want me to
bring jenny's ice cream into this mix
right now
because you won't stand a chance brother
they just released a flavor with dolly
parton
you i'm sorry vayne could go toe to toe
with jenny's
all right you wanna now i like these
niche cookie shops i didn't say i didn't
oh what i said was you don't see any
national chain
cookie restaurants like you do with ice
cream because buddy
buddy what an ice cream chain is an ice
cream shop that serves ice cream an ice
cream
ice cream restaurant there's not gonna
be a cookie restaurant it's a [ __ ]
cookie
all right let me get back to the ice
cream and [ __ ] okay i don't want ice
cream in december
and i don't want ice cream all the time
and people are lactose intolerant can't
even eat ice cream and you ever tried
the
i have to eat it because i have a
lactose problem if you must know
and you're still arguing for ice cream
you can't even eat the things
i eat tell me when you can eat a cookie
and be like i can't eat cookies my body
will reject them
i'm off carbs i can't eat cookies yeah
okay
i ice cream i gotta be in the mood for
okay actually i'm gonna be in the mood
for
okay and you know what happens when i
try to eat ice cream too i get a
sour milk taste in my mouth oh stop it
coffee breath or cigarette breath
you can't eat ice cream and then
continue on a date
you gotta pop a a big red or something
like
oh really you brush before bed what a
revolutionary
wow you're a madman you actually clean
your teeth before you go to sleep like
every person
ice cream is overrated ice cream is
overrated
this is insanity it's good it's a good
treat i have never seen a man eat more
ice cream than this man sitting across
the fact that he is trying to make this
argument
why are you attributing things to me
that are not true why look me in the
eyes and tell me why
what do you mean you've never seen so
many more ice cream than me that's a
bold
faced lie first of all first of all it's
bald-faced lie
first of all no not boldface no
bald-faced lie
what does that mean etymology i don't
know etymology
it's bald-faced lie b-a-l-d it's
bald-faced
sorry hold on hold on click
bold or bolt
all right the classier one is bald face
oh so both
both are both are used but it's no no so
both are used
i was i had a quick question first time
long time
which was first which was first but but
which was first but you berated me
which was first well a lot of different
terms are used commonly now because
people are too dumb to remember
the the regular version of it so which
was first
you just go right there it's right there
the current status of this tree of lie
and liar descriptions is this
both bold faced and bald-faced are used
but boldface is decidedly the preferred
term okay
thank you very much okay thank you very
much so bald-faced
is that what you want to be called
because that's what you did
why i have why why are you saying that
you've never seen so many more ice
creams
i couldn't tell you the last time i had
ice cream i couldn't even tell you on
trips
where i watched you eat ice cream every
single night for dessert along with
cakes and pies
joe that is a lie it's not right
name the trip and name the ice cream
name the trip
poconos go ahead poconos sure we
every night made bowls of combined ice
creams and cakes
i everything i didn't do it every night
look at him laughing look at him
laughing because he knows they're
telling the truth
okay first of all everyone had treats
all week ice cream cookies
we rented a home we were like with 10
people everyone ate ice cream
it was summer so just because no was it
no no no it wasn't
no it wasn't no it wasn't it was it was
it was a it was
april it was not the summer i didn't eat
ice cream on that trip
you are i didn't ice cream on that trip
i just don't even understand what ice
cream
what's the ice cream what's the ice
cream you're right how do you use this
you ate it every day you purchased it
what was the ice cream how do you sleep
at night
i didn't purchase it you purchased it
you said the whole house ate ice cream
every day every night we would stand
around the kitchen island and make these
what was the ice cream i don't remember
yeah taste buddies
we all love food around this place you
know it we know it
but sometimes you got to cut down on the
carbs sometimes you got to cut down on
the sugar
sometimes you just got to cut back in
general but why
when you cut back do you have to deprive
yourself of those delicious
treats that you love so much you don't
number one not anymore of those being
cereal right yeah you talked about this
uh magic spoon is what we're talking
about the magic spoon comes in
am i wrong no it's a zero grams of sugar
cereal
it's got 13 to 14 grams of protein in
each serving
and it's only got four net grams of
carbs
in each serving of the cereal yeah what
else does it have let's see
it's only 140 calories per serving uh
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb and gmo
free that's a lot of freeze a lot of
stuff you're getting free there
they're not going to charge you for the
gluten they're not going to charge you
for the grain
they're not charging for the soy all
free sorry
edit and we've got some exciting news
magic spoon is
relaunching the blueberry flavor one of
the favorite flavors that was it was out
of stock and now it's back in stock
it was sold out you couldn't get it that
was my favorite one of all the ones
did you have a mix because i like mixing
did you ever take the chocolate
and the peanut butter and then make
chocolate peanut butter you know i'm not
a wild
guy like that i try to keep it you know
i keep everything in its own lane
i don't love chocolate cereals as you
know i know but when i mix the chocolate
and the peanut butter together it made a
nice
midday treat i'll tell you this the
blueberry so delicious
didn't need to be mixed that's it and
that's it if you're listening from
canada magic spoon now ships there as
well and you can also build your own box
don't forget uh there's available
flavors to build your very own
custom bundle uh and those flavors are
cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter and
cinnamon so i guess then in
oh oh okay so you could build a bundle
of those sure you can't mix it in this
mixing your frosted with your cinnamon
all right we're not getting we haven't
gone there yet it's magic spoon it's not
miracle spoon
it's only a matter of time go to
magicspoon.com tastebuds to grab some
blueberry
or a custom bundle of cereal we'll try
it today and be sure to use our promo
code
tastebuds at checkout to save five
dollars off your first order
this offer is now good anywhere in the
us or canada as you mentioned
but only when you use our code at
checkout that's right magicspoon.com
tastebuds use promo code tastebuds save
yourself five bucks off your first order
take it easy folks at this time is
at this point in time is there anyone
who doesn't know what blue chew is
i i i would be surprised is there a
podcast listener that does not know what
it is in case you don't let me tell them
right now the most erect human being
on the planet is a podcast listener yeah
yeah that is true
you ask somebody they listen to the
podcast and they say yes
enthusiastically
just peek down just peek down see if
they're pitching a tent at that time
because blue chew is all over the map
baby yeah and if you are
uh somebody who is uh
the unanointed we'll call it uh bluechu
is a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in a chewable form which
is nice and it's at a fraction of the
cost
these uh blue chew tablets help
men achieve harder stronger erections to
combat
all forms of erectile dysfunction i we
call it ed where i come from
it's an online prescription service too
so there's no visit to the doctor's
office
no awkward conversations uh no waiting
in line to pharmacy that's it ships
right to your door
in a discreet package i think that's
important yes process is real simple
here guys
sign up at i say guys because this is a
male based product this is not
for females this is only for men uh sign
up at bluetooth.com
you're gonna consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you're gonna receive
your prescription within days
the best part it's all done online blue
chews licensed
medical providers will work with you to
find the right ingredient and strength
for your prescription
if you don't like swallowing pills
there's no problems here this is a
chewable taste it's
in the title anyway we got a special
offer for our listeners
as does every podcast as well
uh try bluetooth free when you use our
promo code taste buds
at checkout you just pay five bucks for
shipping that's
i will tell you we do a lot of head
reads we say it all the time this one's
for shipping you're paying and you're
getting the product free
can't beat that it's bluechew.com promo
code tastebuds
to receive your first month free and uh
thank you bluechu for for being such a
ubiquitous podcast sponsor including
ourselves
here's wishing all of you harder longer
lasting erections
from us and our families to yours
right oh sure he doesn't remember it was
never good every night
but it wasn't cookies but you can't even
remember anything the brand the flavor
anything at all because i don't remember
eating the ice cream not only
every night let's go let's go to a
carnival
tomorrow i'll tell you what let's let me
take you to a carnival affair hold on a
second hold on a second
he means april 2020. he just stood here
and told me
i eat ice cream every time he sees me i
said i didn't see that
no
i said i've i've never seen people
somebody eat more ice cream i've seen
this many
which is true
are you insane because we went because
we went
to the supermarket and bought food for
the week and there was ice cream in the
freezer at the house we ran
and you saw me eat ice cream you think
that i will not i'm the ice cream guy
i will not sit here i will not sit here
and allow you to say
ice cream is overrated and that you get
a sour taste in your mouth
it's good but you know what you're nuts
it's good but the last bite is not as
good as the first bite
oh like any food that's ever existed i
think cause cookies are enough where
you're not eating so many that the last
bite is no longer any good
you could eat a nice sized cookie in
three or four bites so you wear the bowl
of ice cream by the end
i'm like all right like i'm getting a
little like it's like you ever get a
shake because the shake is very close to
ice cream to me
and i love shakes because it's made out
of ice cream i understand that
yeah i know i didn't think it was made
out of really
really nice he's getting it he's getting
me there yeah yeah
yeah he's getting a hamburger
because they make so much goddamn shake
and then before you know it you're
drinking 32 ounces of shake
that first half of that shake is like
when it hits your tongue
you're like oh you're you're doing a
little dance inside
and then by the end of it you like it's
it's like shakes like 10
bucks and you got to finish it you feel
wasteful by the end of it i'm sucking
down that shaker and listen to what you
just said no more room inside my body
and i'm like
oh and every time i'm like oh my god i'm
full of creams
i'm just full of milk and cream listen
to what you just said
what you said they give you extra shake
because they make
32 ounces of shake they make so much
shake you're complaining that you're
giving
way too much shake and then you feel
sick that's like me saying
cookies suck because when i order them
when i buy them in the store
there's three sleeves and by that third
sleeve i feel sick to my stomach i don't
order
i don't care you're arguing you're
cooking you're arguing
one shake right you're arguing gluttony
sweet people are giving you too much
shake for your money i'm giving you
a serving they're giving you a shake
that's not for sure
no in america it is a gluttonous amount
of shake they give you and you know that
bro all i'm saying is that by the end of
that shake just like by the end of a
bowl of ice cream
i'm loaded up on cream and i don't feel
don't you dare
don't you dare you cannot compare a
reasonably sized bowl of ice cream to
what they give you in a restaurant with
a
with a drinkable shake that's not fair
and you know it's not fair
the point i'm trying to make is when i'm
usually when i'm done with even the cone
sometimes you ever get a cone
they put one two three three scoops
that's why they say do you want how many
scoops by the end of it i'm like
they literally give you the option to
give you the
option of how many you want to know a
hack i learned about 20 years ago
what you got an ice cream cone before
you put the ice cream in it
drop a mini marshmallow in the cone it
acts as a
stopper for the ice cream dripping
through the bottom that's smart
i know what it is that's why she had it
but so far your
your argument right now against ice
cream sounds like you don't understand
what a shoot
a ghost sounds like a cookie out of the
oven it's crispy on the outside and
chewy on the inside
and you break it apart and there's
possibly walnuts
or macadamias you've got linzer tarts do
you want to talk about cookie selection
i go everywhere from the swiss fudge
from stelladoro sure homemade chocolate
chips right to the lid
anywhere from rocky road to chubby hubby
i mean what are you talking about here
that's not the point a cookie i have it
i all shapes and sizes all densities all
textures you dunk it in milk you don't
dunk it in milk
okay i like i mean it's just so much
happening with the cookies you are going
to get
creamed
a cake versus a brownie versus ice cream
a cookie has
all the ingredients a cookie has some
highlights of a cake but it's also its
own thing
i love a cookie i love eating this i
love the serving size of the cookies
don't even listen to me when i'm looking
at you making a point you just look up
there
because you read the page we're going to
the phones
we're going to the phones already where
are we at right now
28 minutes let's go to nowhere all right
i'm sorry i thought well pimp pulled up
the comments i thought we were
i thought it was time ice cream
hold on you didn't let me finish my
point first of all
okay your argument against ice cream is
my
my tummy my tummy my tummy it sounds
like you don't know what a reasonable
portion is
and that's not ice cream's fault that's
your fault you want to go in and get in
over your head over uh over with ice
cream then that's your problem
that's not i'm not saying you might tell
me you're the one who said my tummy
because you're lactose intolerant no i
didn't
you're saying when you eat a bowl of ice
cream you feel sick after no you don't
if you eat a reasonably sized bowl of
ice cream you don't feel sick after i'm
saying so the end of a bowl of ice cream
is not the same as the beginning of a
bowl of ice cream i feel like
no food is i get it i'm eating iced
cream i get it it's like a lot of the
same thing
it tastes good and you're telling me the
last bite of a cookie
is so diversely different from the first
bite of a cookie
no because the cookie is only a few
bites
okay but how many end of a cookie okay
by the fifth cookie you think
you're you're still wowed by the cookies
no you're like i know what i'm eating
cookie's just better bro i like the
texture of a cookie better i like the
options of taste from a cookie better
i like that you could have them hot or
cold i like that you could dunk them
i mean a cookie for me i know that ice
cream has this like summertime ice cream
truck thing to it
but i'm not saying it's not an a-level
treat but if i had to choose between
cookies and ice cream i'm going cookies
every time so in the rest of the day of
summer you're taking a hot cookie out of
the oven over
ice cream yeah oh stop if i'm in the
mood i'm not saying oh
stop hold on you're making the argument
to me just now that
that i'll never be in the mood for ice
cream over a cookie that's not what i'm
saying
you said i never want ice cream in the
winter time that's what you said
yeah but i'm not saying that i'll always
i'll always
okay i'll never that logic you'll never
want a hot cookie in the summer
no i i would have a hot cookie in the
summer but you'll never have ice cream
in the winter
i didn't say i would never have it but
you said to me you don't crave an ice
cream sundae on a december day
that's not what i said you said you
don't like ice cream in the winter
and i said a hot fudge sundae ice
cream's big time to shine is the summer
monsters
in the winter ice cream just goes
into a freezer and it keeps to itself
okay i think that again
i'll give you another argument i'll give
you another argument one of my favorite
ice creams
chocolate chip cookie dough again ice
cream saying
come to my party is
cookie dough with ice cream this is ice
cream
with cookie dough that's so stupid it's
not stupid
you know that from my heart to that it's
not stupid because to me
that means we need cookie dough to make
this the star of this ice cream flavor
we're using the cookies it's a nice
twist okay but if
then then have something without cookie
dough then i do all the time no but i'm
saying you're saying that ice cream is
like
come join us you need to when i'm saying
that no you're bringing cookie into the
mix
you're using the cookie the ice cream is
using the cookie cookie's not using the
ice cream
just curious pimp if you could google
yeah oreo ice cream flavor here we go
here we go oreo ice cream flavor let's
see let's see if oreos have brought ice
cream what's the store there
look at that look at that right out of
the game look at that
oreo ice cream flavor yeah i have a
question for you i'm glad you brought
this up
cookies and cream is arguably one of the
most popular flavors of ice cream would
you say
i mean you have your chocolate and
vanilla maybe your strawberry then you
have stuff like
chocolate chip mint chocolate chip just
really powerful you're gonna come in
here with the balls to say that oreo is
responsible for cookies and cream i know
it was an ice cream that was first
that said oreo you can come into our
party the star
we'll collab well calaba or ice cream is
to kanye in that mix saying i'm inviting
you to collabo with me
the star of course you didn't create ice
cream which is arguably the most
it could have the most without ice cream
it's the cookies it couldn't exist
without ice cream cookies it's not ice
cream and cookies it's it's not cream
and cookies is it
it's cookies and creams who is top billy
who has top billing
it's cookies and cream you don't go oh i
could go for cream and cookies you're
crazy you're insane cookies and cream is
based on the oreo
it might be the most popular ice cream
player of all time and it's because of
the cookie it's ice cream saying hey we
like what you guys are doing over there
with your milk and your [ __ ]
why don't you come join us in the ice
cream party why don't you come hang with
the big boys
no it's the big ice cream would as a
matter of fact ice cream would fall on
its keister
if it wasn't for other flavors you got
chocolate vanilla really strawberry says
the guy that voted and fought for
vanilla flavored ice cream because it's
great
you do you so now you're trying to bring
all these other flavors
that's because they're like all right
what are we going to do besides be
chocolatey
ingredients or blueberries oh yeah
pineapple blueberry ice cream yeah i
love those yeah no they're real no no
blueberry milkshake it'll change your
life oh yeah no no i'm saying
that's a common that's that's a good
thing to put up against oh it's only at
denny's the most common restaurant in
all of the countries
has a blueberry milk totally right but
yeah let me do um let me do a um
uh a chocolate walnut fresh baked cookie
versus pineapple ice cream
pineapple ice cream you'll find in the
store great
yeah you'll find it uh uh that's a great
flavor
ice cream you will find it mint ice
cream coffee flavored ice cream
yeah these are all common you know what
the star coffee flavored ice cream is
joe coffee you know what the store
flavored ice cream is
mint you see what the star of cookie
flavored ice cream is cookie that's how
ice cream works
is ice cream is that mixed okay you know
what the star of chocolate chip cookies
is
chocolate you know what the star of
peanut butter cookies is peanut butter
you know what the star of oatmeal
cookies is
oatmeal chocolate is a main ingredient
in
chocolate chip cookies
right right vanilla ice cream adding
oreos to it to make it cookies is the
main ingredient in mint flavored ice
cream
folks a lot of you by now have heard
about hello fresh it's a great
service it's a great product but if you
haven't heard about it here's what it is
you're going to get fresh
pre-measured ingredients and
mouth-watering seasonal recipes
delivered right
to your door you're going to skip your
trips to the grocery store which can
always be a pain
especially after a long day at work or
doing whatever
and you can count on hellofresh to make
your home cooking easy
fun and affordable that's important
right now
that's the most important right now
affordable and that's why
it's america's number one meal kit
there's a lot of meal kits out there but
this is tops
joe can i jump in and tag team with you
here please okay hello fresh cuts out
stressful meal planning and grocery
store
trips so you can enjoy cooking and get
dinner on the table in about 30 minutes
or less that's a cool thing that they do
where it's meals ready in 20 minutes or
less
lightening uh prep recipes and quick
breakfast and lunches it's perfect for
someone with a busy schedule
yeah there's a wide variety of easy
delicious options for all three meals of
the day
plus every snack and special treat in
between and hellofresh is 28
cheaper than shopping at the grocery
store and 72
cheaper than a restaurant meal without
sacrificing quality and i'll tell you
what i like
particularly about hellofresh i'm
somebody that enjoys cooking and i am
somebody that will cook from scratch
absolutely make hours long meals you
know that take a long time to prep and
cook whatever
i've used hellofresh and i will say that
given the speed
of this you are not losing a bit of
quality which is astounding to me
the fact that you were able to get a
meal this quality this quickly
is just something that's very hard to
come by when you're cooking it yourself
it's all about convenience these days
nobody wants to leave the house
especially during
uh well a pandemic
anyway go to hellofresh.com tastebuds 12
that's hellofresh.com
tastebuds 12. you're going to use the
code
tastebuds 12. are you ready for this to
get 12
free meals including free shipping
so we're just shipping out food here
hello it's amazing
that's four days worth of food and
snacks
delivered for free to you by
hellofresh.com
tastebuds 12 using the promo code
tastebuds 12
you're gonna get 12 free meals including
free shipping from america's
number one meal kit hellofresh hey joe
happy sunday
happy sunday man i spent sundays at home
how about you
i do too and you might be asking me why
i zoomed you today
uh i think i might know why you zoomed
me
but uh i i love your lovely apartment
and i love being in my lovely apartment
i'm sorry we're not together
but you know home is where the heart is
as they say
and is your home in short joe sal i'm a
big believer in insurance
for the car for the home for whatever i
think you need to get it and i'm hearing
about
a new company that's out there that's
changing the game just a bit it's why i
called joe i want to talk to you about
gabby
okay when it comes to car and home
insurance show don't we deserve better
i know that i do we do well so do i
don't leave me out of it
yeah and people are putting their
policies to the test and turning into
gabby do you know what gabby stands for
joe
no i just thought it was like a really
nice name actually it is a beautiful
name but gabby
actually stands for get a better
insurance and getting better insurance
with gabby means a better price for the
same exact insurance coverage
who knew something like this existed joe
because i did not
that's very honestly that's very clever
because i like that it was called gabby
and the fact just because i like the
name gabby it sounds so much better than
like
you know prudential insurer or whatever
you know so
uh and the fact that it stands for
something is great and i will say this
about gabby they are
one true comparison platform with real
rates
which is really cool because you can go
on and get apples to apples comparisons
of your current coverage
with 40 of the top insurance providers
like progressive
or nationwide and travelers and it's all
in one place
so they're not providers they're just
letting you find the best insurance for
yourself
sure and what's wild about this
conversation is i thought i was
informing you about them
but then you had a load of information
and specifics about them yourself
so let me one-up you you can use your
current insurance information joe to get
started in just
minutes you'll be able to see quotes for
the exact same coverage you currently
have
and it's all free to use let me flip the
script on you
i'm going to you i'm going to one-up you
again because i i know and
i i know i know somebody okay okay
and they've used gabby all right you
want to talk about fast you want to talk
about easy
you're talking about gabby okay they
told me they were paying way too much
for their insurance for too long of a
time
they went over to gabby they realized
how much they were overpaying
all right yes uh they also mentioned
that logging in with their current
provider when they were
looking to switch it took too long it
was too laborious
uh and they went over to gabby they got
a ton of quotes
they saved uh well let me let me jump in
there and one up you
okay so let me let me jump in and one up
you with some information i have because
gabby customers
save on average 961.
a year can you believe that and they'll
never sell your info
so no annoying spam no robocalls you're
safe with gap yeah
i was going to say you have to say about
that what do you have to say about that
i was going to say my friend saved
hundreds of dollars i didn't want to get
gauche about it but i do like that you
brought up a number
okay because i like a number and
speaking of numbers
well not a number a website i'd like you
to do this put your policy to the test
like so many people people are doing get
a better insurance
through gabby it's totally free to check
and there's no obligation just go to
gabby dot com slash
taste buds that's g-a-b-i dot com
slash taste buds gabby.com slash
taste buds go check it out see what you
get 100
and that's really all i needed to talk
to you about today so i'm going to go i
know me too
all right good talking now this was on
my mind sometimes i got it out in the
open
i still love you i still love you too
and that love is insured
peaches are the main ingredient in peach
flavored ice cream peach flavored ice
cream
yes joe cherry flavored ice cream i do
like cherry garcia
who doesn't let's go to the phones go to
the phones let's go to the phones
let's go to the phones i think i think i
think i think that
with lactose intolerance and the winter
and the fact that really kids are eating
i believe cookies
and are braised on cookies more than
they're raised on ice cream for the ice
cream truck
right i think that people grow into
adulthood
having more of a bond
and a connection with yeah because you
never because you because you know how
you see kids freak out about cookies the
way they do about ice cream you know
that's
you know how kids will go oh my gosh
there's an ice cream fix
there's a cookies fixings bar they freak
out about the truck because they're in
the
plane
you scream because no ice cream and now
there's ice cream
you drive a truck down the street
playing a nice jingle i don't care
what's in it
i don't care what's in it you can put
cigarettes in there and it's like
cheetah
and if i'm in a sprinkle i'm gonna be
like oh cigarettes i'll tell you what
i'll tell you what your man's got a few
dollars why don't you put your money
where your mouth is
let's put your money whether your mouth
is i want you to go start a cookie's
truck with a jingle and i want to see
how well it does out there for you
you've got the cash at the top at the
top of this don't try to bring me into
your food business
do it at the top of this episode you
were like there's no such thing as a
cookie truck
he googled it and 30 came up oh he found
six niche cookie trucks on the outskirts
of austin texas
where they have weird food trucks a ice
cream truck is a
thing is a function of someone trying to
survive
effect ice cream truck is a it's not
it's a meat
better than cookies it's a staple all
right you know okay you know what
can't wait to go to grandma's house i
can't wait for this special holiday
can't wait for mom's fresh baked cookies
grandma's fresh baked cookies a basket
of cookies
cookies on a picnic let's bake cookies
together kids you just said people
aren't making ice cream every night in
their homes
cookies are being baked between families
grandparents and parents
i came to your house i brought my
[ __ ] books i grew up i went to the
bakery i bought a two-pack i grew up
cookies
seven-layered rainbow crops talking to
you that thought i grew up in an italian
like we brought you my famous ice cream
are you nuts no one comes to someone i
grew up in a cow made ice cream i grew
up in an italian household
homemade cookies were a huge thing but
you can't find them in an italian
restaurant well you will find tiramisu
and every fancy italian ice cream
flavor just go into any bakery anywhere
and look at the cookie selection most of
them are derived
from italian foods we didn't even talk
about italian cookies or bakery cookies
those blow ice cream out of the water
hands down those are like
god's gift to cookies you walk in a
bakery and smell the cookies
it must be what heaven smells let's go
to the phones let's see what the people
have to say i'm saying
nobody's like oh my grandma's passing
down this recipe
from 1910 her ice cream recipe it's a
raisin
i hear recipes of sauce and gravy and
things of this nature be
soups recipes being passed out i've
never heard somebody say
uh my grandma makes the best walnut
raisin cookies i went to the bakery
we bought two pounds of cookies i
brought you my famous homemade cookies
where do you try my grandmother's
cookies
let's kids let's get together let's bake
cookies together cookies and milk baby
cookies i would like to see what the
people have to say
cookies are so much better can't even
eat ice cream fast ice cream headaches
because it's too good it's like a drug
too much
some of the worst moments of my life
worst moments of my life for like little
spurts of a minute at a time
have been when i thought i was going to
die from an ice cream headache oh would
you
ever you have you have a square in the
eye of an ice cream headache storm
and you don't know when you're coming
out of it it's it's let's go right away
you get a reward another cookie you eat
ice cream too fast
you can't you think your head's gonna
explode and you don't want that you have
spiders
people have ptsd from eating ice cream
too fast you've said your ptsd
you've said your piece the polls are
closed
we are going to the phones there's a
show to do here
i'm just thinking of extra things i'm
not gonna okay i thought of ice cream
headache
and i'm not gonna i mean bite you can't
even bite into ice cream
hunter shouldn't have bite into it
hunter's [ __ ] yeah she'll lick it yeah
and then you have the liquid hunter says
it's so much maintenance right you can't
bite it
you can't eat it too fast ice cream ice
cream ice cream you can't eat it too
fast
can't need it too slow you're on a clock
with ice cream
yeah you're gonna burn your teeth right
get a splitting headache when you think
your eyeballs are gonna pop out or
you're gonna get stickiness
it's kind of like the time limit you
have on that steaming hot cookie you're
always eating
fresh out of your oven versus cooking
versus the tree bark you pull out of
your cupboard
versus the tree bark you pull out of
your cupboard
until it's edible out of the oven okay
this cookie just came out of the oven
would you like it now
or in a week because in one week it'll
be just as fast oh yeah yeah
because they don't go standing
hurry up and eat that
we have a show to do we have to go to
the phones
hunter says the argument is for a better
dessert not a better snack
cookies are a phenomenal snack but when
i want a dessert i go for the ever
versatile ice cream
cone sundae shakes sandwiches the
possibilities are endless i've never
gone
hey babe let's have some cookies for
dessert excellent now
i think that's [ __ ] because he's
making cookies into a snack when cookies
are a dessert too
give me a break i didn't say better
snack i said better dessert don't take
it now and make cookies a snack
what are you saying the argument is for
better dessert and cookies don't count
as a dessert
that's what he said keep saying that's
not right to do
because cookies are a dessert just
because he says cookies are a snack he's
not going to take my whole argument he's
not going to kick
chop the knees or chop me off of the
knees i don't care if he thinks it's a
snack
maggie tonk says no he's like an ark is
a nut or a pretzel
cookie is a dessert cookie's a dessert
in your world
in your weird world that you live in
yeah and you
yeah you you sound good
put out the poll he goes just put better
dessert
but i'm saying man you're saying it's a
snack now because i
said what i'm saying it doesn't hold up
as a good dessert oh god you see what
you did hunter
you made dad and dad argue shall go out
so i'll go out to a michelin star
restaurant
and then after after the whole meal will
go you have fruit roll-ups
can we have some fruit rolls for dessert
that's a great dessert
that's that's a snack uh anyway joe
before you read anymore look at me again
joe you think cookie is a snack or
eating cookie's a dessert
say dessert let's move on because you're
saying it's a snack and it's not
now you like it to get to a fruit i
think it can count as a dessert
but it doesn't hold a candle to a
dessert in the ice cream department
that's what i'm saying
that's a fair argument you're a terrible
person
uh no i'm not you just made a [ __ ]
argument you picked the wrong
argument okay let's see what maggie i
didn't hear much from you let's see what
maggie
i actually heard uh can we just read the
comments
please it's when you get on the uh it's
you're you say stuff i
can't make your [ __ ] argument good i
don't know what to tell you
you say maggie i gotta be honest i
picture people watching this thing just
turning beat red with fury
over some of the statements you make
what did i mean you don't you don't you
don't argue
fair you you said better dessert apple
argument was better dessert your
argument was better dessert
you pulled better dessert cookies are
going to win this
okay maggie talk says
ice cream always ice cream cookies are
snacks
or for breakfast when you're ran out of
cocoa pops
there is no better dessert than ice
cream that's why there are ice cream
parlors you don't have cookie parlors
whoever chooses cookies needs to take a
long hard look at themselves that's
everything i said
in three sentences uh you guys
the fact that an ice cream parlor exists
has no weight in whether it's better
than the cookie okay
all right well everybody seems to feel a
little differently can you scroll up
again
on the contrary cookies are much more
accessible and a lot easier to make
the best ice cream toppings are all
cookie based too thank you
that's what i said your ice cream needs
help from the cooking was the last time
you had an ice cream flavored cookie
oh right you didn't because cookies
don't need ice cream like ice cream
oh actually i thought he was with me
that need these cookies ice cream has to
bow down to the cookie i thought that's
a contender for our best uh reply
uh cookies are the hotel bed sheet
tucked too tight into the mattress
of the dessert world if you can even
call it dessert because it's not
it is in fact a snack oh what is your
people
well i don't know it's weird it's almost
like everybody's right because the
the idea is i mean cookie is a dessert
are we insane
definitely is a snackable maybe because
the portion of one
is not big enough to to be considered
the full dessert
so you need a few of them and i think
that's why they're snack a bowl i just
think it's interesting i don't think
they're snacks
so many people are making my exact art
if you had a mini comb which i have
downstairs in my fridge right now i have
these little mini cones
from trader joe's i can't eat it but
i wouldn't call that a i would call that
a snack because of the size of it so
you're talking about a specific product
versus people are getting hung up on the
fact that a cookie is a single cookie
because
people don't eat cookies that much for
dessert i hate to break it to you
i know you think that this is a common
dessert it's a dessert it's sugar it's a
confection it's sweet it's a dessert
i choose cookies you definitely kiss
your grandma i'm on the lips i don't
trust you
if you choose cookies you definitely
kiss your grandma's lips i don't trust
you thanks
crap crap crap bag is our winner so far
for best card
you kiss your grandmother if you eat
cookies you're incestual
it's a funny argument about that bad
statement from a crap bag come on have
you ever had hand cranked peach ice
cream in the summer sure i love cookies
but screw you guys on this oh yeah
because that's it yeah because you know
what everyone in the summer is having
hand cranked peach
have you ever tried dipping ice cream in
tea case clothes
thank you thank you not even milk bro
not even milk let's talk about hot
chocolate
coffee tea let's talk about all the
things you could dunk a cookie into
cookie and tea hot a hot tea with a
cookie in it
there's so many it's so versatile once
again the cookie is so versatile
the ice cream is like i need to i can't
do a thing to make it better
like all right look we're gonna throw a
bunch of [ __ ] in it but no matter what
it's probably gonna be a base flavor
oh yeah and that's not what cookies are
gonna be chocolate vanilla
whatever that you throw stuff in vanilla
strawberry and then throw a bunch of
[ __ ] into it and then eat it right away
eat it right but not too fast cookies
ice cream cookies are literally better
than
christ flesh above communion winters if
you will
that's our winner that's our winner
bimbo
bimbo summit is our winner follow bimbo
summit at
volpe's vulpies which is at
v-u-l-p-e-s-v-u-l-p-e-s
okay pimp let's go to the polls let's
see who won this thing
come on man please go well okay come on
come on baby
the cold embrace of
ice cream failure ice cream
63.8 percent
to cookies which scored a measly
36.2 percent i can't believe you even
attempted this
i can't believe you even tried to take
this
into the ring but you did and you lost
but you know what sal i still love you i
love you too
that's our show thanks for listening to
the taste buds take it easy we'll see
you next time
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds